[Música]
vamos a las noticias de la salud con más
Romero salamar Buen día para usted
Buenos días Ángela vamos a comenzar en
Chile donde el Ministerio de salud
anunció un primer caso de gripe aviar en
humanos no es nuevo el tema pero hay que
recordarlo si tenemos que ir
actualizando la información es el primer
caso en humanos que se detecta en Chile
el segundo en este brote en la región el
primero fue en Ecuador y es el tercero
en la historia del continente americano
las autoridades de chile dieron la
siguiente información
se trata de una persona de sexo
masculino de 53 años que tuvo un cuadro
de influenza grave compromiso de
extracto respiratorio bajo esta persona
está estable en su gravedad está
hospitalizado y en este momento están
los equipos de epidemiología desplegados
en terreno para investigar la fuente de
contacto es el llamativo que salte a
humanos normalmente no sucede es el
virus h5n1 recordemos que está mal
adaptado entre para el contagio no entre
entre personas sin embargo sí sucede
tiene una letalidad de más del 50% es
decir que por eso las autoridades llaman
a un monitoreo no de los contactos
también y de lo que esté sucediendo para
tener claro Cuál es el riesgo en
realidad Sin embargo a pesar de lo
llamativo al final que es que sucedan
estos casos en humanos la verdadera
crisis está en las aves y está en los
animales particularmente por ejemplo en
Chile este virus ya ha provocado la
muerte de más de diez mil Aves Porque
además un contagio suele el sacrificio
de muchas de estas aves de corral no de
granjas por miedo a que se extienda
también se ha detectado en Chile
particularmente en leones marinos las
recomendaciones generales son de nuevo
no manipular animales muertos intentar
evitar el contacto con estos animales y
con las aves si se trabaja con aves
mantener todas las precauciones posibles
de higiene varios países de la región a
propósito maran decretado alertas
sanitarias a raíz de la gripe aviar esto
ya casi que se veía venir Si se veía
venir desde hace tiempo que este virus
estaba comportando de una forma un poco
particular y los expertos ya están
hablando del concepto de panzottia que
es una pandemia en animales Vamos a
repasar los países donde se han
detectado en Casos algunos casos vemos
en Amarillo por ejemplo los que se han
detectado en aves silvestres hay una
ruta muy clara migratoria además por
toda la costa pacífica del continente
que provoca esto también hay países
donde se han encontrado en áreas de
traspatio es decir en las casas de las
personas es importante destacarlo Porque
eso significa que hay un contacto
estrecho con los humanos y por último
también hay países como Canadá chile
Estados Unidos y Perú donde el virus se
ha detectado en mamíferos esto es
importante porque entonces significa que
podría estar adaptándose mejor al
contagio en las especies mamíferas no
forma parte de una de las nuevas
dinámicas de este brote también es la
expansión tan larga tan grande en
América cuando no solía ser así fuera de
la estacionalidad habitual entonces
bueno lleva la comunidad científica de
nuevo a pedir no despertar la alarma
para la salud de las personas pero sí
pedir este monitoreo cercano estrecho
para saber qué está sucediendo con estas
nuevas dinámicas vamos a pasar a la
actualización de otro brote que seguimos
monitoreando el del virus de marburgo si
en este caso hablamos del brote en
Guinea ecuatorial del que ahora
desarrollaremos más información pero
también recordar que hay otro brote de
virus de marburgo que se está
desarrollando en tanzania en la OMS ayer
hizo un llamado a que el gobierno de
Guinea ecuatorial habla de todos los
casos que tenía registrados escuchémoslo
el número de casos oficiales reportados
permanece en 9,7 muertes en tres
provincias
sin embargo esas tres provincias están a
150 kilómetros de distancia lo que
sugiere una propagación más amplia
la OMS es consciente de nuevos casos y
ha pedido al gobierno reportarlos
oficialmente
es después de estos comentarios de la
Organización Mundial de la Salud que
efectivamente las autoridades de Guinea
ecuatorial reconocieron 13 casos
confirmados nueve de estas personas han
fallecido una persona está en
recuperación es muy importante tener
toda esta información para controlar
Cómo se está expandiendo teniendo en
cuenta además que los últimos casos se
han detectado en la ciudad de bata que
es una ciudad portuaria y es un motor
económico del país por lo que hay más
potencial de expansión no recordamos
también que este virus es una fiebre
hemorrágica muy parecida al ébola no hay
tratamientos no hay vacunas en este caso
que funcionen para contrarrestar solo un
manejo de los síntomas y sin un buen
manejo de los síntomas la letalidad
puede llegar a ser del 88% estamos
hablando de un virus bastante bastante
peligroso mar vamos a terminar con el
covid 19 y las nuevas guías de la OMS
para la vacunación contra esta
enfermedad Sí esta semana las emitieron
sobre todo el grupo de expertos para el
19 de la OMS y básicamente lo que
dijeron es dividir la población en las
personas con riesgo alto riesgo medio
riesgo bajo los en riesgo alto son los
adultos mayores de 60 años y también
todas las personas que tienen un sistema
inmunitario comprometido además de los
trabajadores sanitarios para ellos
recomiendan un refuerzo anual o cada
seis meses según sus condiciones de
salud sin embargo les recomiendan estos
refuerzos anuales para toda la población
que esté en riesgo medio o bajo es decir
adultos menores de 60 años o niños y
adolescentes Para quienes no hacen falta
de hecho particularmente para niños y
adolescentes que es una población que
que el Kobe 19 no les afectaba tanto
pues llamaron a reevaluar la prioridad
de esa vacunación no es que sea insegura
no es que sea mala no es que les vaya a
hacer daño pero pues volvieron a
insistir en que quizás era importante
priorizar estos otros grupos no la misma
Organización Mundial de la Salud decía
recientemente que el fin de la pandemia
a pesar de mantener por ahora todavía el
estatus de emergencia sanitaria
internacional estaba a la vista y Esto
va un poco al final en la misma línea no
es un sistema muy parecido al de la
gripe Que es esta vacuna regular para
las personas que están en riesgo parece
sí que estamos en una situación muy
definitivamente muy diferente a la de
2020 con tanta población ya que ya se ha
vacunado que también ya se ha contagiado
y que eso da una inmunidad muy distinta
pues a toda la población pues más le
agradezco por las guías de cuidado que
nos entrega y nos vemos mañana nos vemos
mañana Ángela